ASTRONAUTS BACK TO THE MOON
AFTER ITS FIRST ARTEMIS MISSION
ENDS SUCCESSFULLY.
YOU'RE IN THE "CNN NEWSROOM."
>>> WELL, WE HAVE SOME NEW
REPORTING COMING INTO THE CNN
NEWS ROM TONIGHT ABOUT JACK
SMITH, THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
INVESTIGATING FORMER PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP DONALD TRUMP AND A
PAIR OF CRIMINAL PROBES.
I WANT TO BRING IN KATELYN
POLANTZ, SHE IS CNN'S SENIOR
CRIME AND JUSTICE REPORTER.
SHE JOINS US WITH THE LATEST.
SO BASED ON YOUR REPORTING,
SMITH'S TEAM IS MOVING QUICKLY.
WE SAW A GLIMPSE OF THAT WITH
THESE SUBPOENAS THAT WERE ISSUED
TO OFFICIALS IN WISCONSIN AND
MICHIGAN, BUT YOU HAVE A REPORT
ON HOW QUICKLY HIS TEAM IS
MOVING.
AND WHEN COULD WE SEE ACTUAL
CHARGES?
>> PAM, THAT'S GOING TO BE THE
QUESTION EVERY DAY GOING
FORWARD.
WHEN CAN WE SEE CHARGES?
WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHEN THAT
WILL HAPPEN.
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
WERE TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IS,
WHAT DOES THIS ACTUALLY LOOK
LIKE NOW THAT THERE IS A SPECIAL
COUNSEL OVER THESE TWO ONGOING
INVESTIGATIONS.
JANUARY 6th AND MAR-A-LAGO.
AND A TEAM OF US TRIED TO DIG
INTO THAT TO GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE SHAPE OF
THESE INVESTIGATIONS AND THIS
OFFICE.
SO KRISTEN HOLMES,
JEREMY HERB, A FEW OTHERS AROUND
OUR JUSTICE TEAM, WE DUG INTO IT
AND LEARNED A FEW THINGS.
ONE, IT DOESN'T -- THIS SEEMS
LIKE IT COULD ALMOST BE OBVIOUS,
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE
TEAM OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
PROSECUTING ESPECIALLY JANUARY
6th CASES ARE ASKING ABOUT IS
INTENT OF DONALD TRUMP.
THE KNOWLEDGE DONALD TRUMP HAD
IN LEADING UP TO JANUARY 6th.
I SAY THAT SEEMS OFFICE.
WE'VE SEEN PEOPLE FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE COUNCIL'S OFFICE, FROM THE
OFFICE OF THE VICE PRESIDENCY
GOING IN AND BEING FORCED TO
GIVE MORE ANSWERS TO A FEDERAL
GRAND JURY, BUT THAT'S NOT
ALWAYS AN OBVIOUS THING THAT
THEY WOULD BE ASKING ABOUT.
WE KNOW THAT THEY'RE LOOKING AT
A LOT OF DIFFERENT THINGS, NOT
JUST TRUMP.
THAT IS ONE THING THAT WE HEARD
AND FOUND.
ANOTHER THING THAT WE LEARNED IS
THAT THERE'S ALWAYS BEEN A HINT
OF THE QUESTION OF FINANCES.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE EXPERTISE IN
PUBLIC CORRUPTION, FRAUD AND
MONEY LAUNDERING, WHO HAVE
STARTED WORKING IN THIS SPECIAL
COUNSEL'S OFFICE, BUT WE DO
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS A
PRETTY SIZABLE FINANCIAL
INVESTIGATION, THAT CONTINUES ON
AS WELL.
>> THAT'S INTERESTING.
WE COVERED THE SPECIAL COUNSEL,
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION
TOGETHER.
WE WERE ON THAT TEAM.
AND THERE IS A DIFFERENCE HERE
WITH THAT INVESTIGATION AND THIS
ONE, THE KEY ONE BEING DONALD
TRUMP IS NO LONGER A SITTING
PRESIDENT.
RIGHT?
HOW DOES THAT CHANGE THE
EQUATION?
>> WELL, PAM, THE FIRST THING
THAT THE MUELLER PROSECUTORS,
THEY BASICALLY KNEW FROM THE
BEGINNING, IT WASN'T CLEAR TO
THE PUBLIC, BUT THEY KNEW THAT
THEY WEREN'T GOING TO BE ABLE TO
CHARGE THE SITTING PRESIDENT,
ESPECIALLY WITH OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
THAT'S NOT THE CASE HERE.
NOW, OUR UNDERSTANDING WAS, EVEN
WHEN, BEFORE THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
CAME IN TO INVESTIGATE AROUND
JANUARY 6th, SOME OF THOSE
PROSECUTORS WERE GIVEN THE
ABILITY TO TAKE AN INVESTIGATION
UP TO TRUMP, IF THEY NEEDED TO.
SO THIS SPECIAL COUNSEL IS
STARTING A LITTLE BIT AT A
DIFFERENT PLACE THAN MUELLER
WAS.
AND ALSO, WITH THAT, OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF THIS SPECIAL
COUNSEL, JACK SMITH, IS THAT
HE'S GOING TO FUNCTION MORE LIKE
A CAREER MANAGER, A U.S.
ATTORNEY, NOT SETTING UP A
SHADOW JUSTICE DEPARTMENT THAT
COULD BE AT ODDS WITH THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, AS HAPPENED
A LITTLE BIT DURING THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
BUT THE OTHER THING, PAM, THAT'S
REALLY FASCINATING ABOUT THIS IS
THAT THIS IS ALREADY A BIGGER
GROUP OF INVESTIGATORS, ALMOST
TWICE THE SIZE OR EVEN MORE WHEN
YOU COMBINE BOTH OF THESE
INVESTIGATIONS, THAN WHAT
MUELLER HAD TO WORK WITH.
>> AND IS HE STILL -- I KNOW HE
WAS RECOVERING FROM KNEE
SURGERY.
IS HE STILL OVERSEAS, OR IS HE
NOW IN THE U.S.?
>> STILL OVERSEAS, WE'RE
WAITING.
AND SO THEY SHOULD BE SETTING UP
AN OFFICE, BUT THE PROSECUTORS,
AS FAR AS WE KNOW, THERE ARE
MANY, MANY OF THEM AND THEY
CONTINUE ON EVERY DAY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
KATELYN POLANTZ, GREAT
REPORTING.
THANKS SO MUCH.
>>> ALSO TONIGHT, SOURCES TELL
ME AND OTHER CNN REPORTERS THAT
THE HOUSE SELECT COMMITTEE
INVESTIGATING JANUARY 6th HAS
ENDED ITS MEETING WHERE MEMBERS
DISCUSS CRIMINAL REFERRALS.
AND ONE SOURCE I SPOKE WITH
TONIGHT JUST BEFORE THE SHOW
SAID THAT IT WAS A SUCCESSFUL
MEETING, IMPLYING THAT PROGRESS
WAS MADE, BUT DIDN'T ELABORATE.
THE SUBCOMMITTEE FOCUSED ON
THOSE REFERRALS PRESENTED ITS
FINDINGS TO THE FULL COMMITTEE,
AND SAYING THAT THE COMMITTEE
HAS AGREED ON A PATH FORWARD ON
REFERRALS.
LAST HOUR, I SPOKE WITH CNN
LEGAL ANALYST, ELIE HONIG ABOUT
WHAT IT ALL MEANS.
>> WELL, PAM, FIRST OF ALL, THE
COMMITTEE ALSO IS IN THE PROCESS
OF DECIDING WHAT THEY'RE GOING
TO DO.
THEY'VE SAID DIFFERENT THINGS IN
THE PAST.
THEY'VE SAID THEY INTEND TO.
THEY SAID TODAY'S MEETING WAS
SUCCESSFUL SO WE'LL SEE WHAT
THEY DO.
WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
ABOUT A CRIMINAL REFERRAL IS
THAT LEGALLY IT HAS NO SPECIFIC
IMPACT.
IT'S NOT BINDING ON DOJ.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO INVESTIGATE
BECAUSE CONGRESS OR ANYBODY ELSE
ASKS THEM TO AND THEY DON'T NEED
TO BE ASKED IN ORDER TO
INVESTIGATE.
THEY CAN DO IT ON THEIR OWN.
WE KNOW DOJ IS ALREADY
INVESTIGATING DONALD TRUMP.
BUT OF COURSE, THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT WAY THAT THE COMMITTEE
WILL HAVE TO THINK ABOUT HOW
THEY WANT TO END THEIR